welcome to a world of ethical
exploration in India a realm of top
launch ethical courses awaits you these
courses not only equip you with
essential skills but also guide you in
making responsible choices so let's
embark on a journey to discover the top
5 ethical courses in India where
learning meets concerns in the most
accessible and engaging way possible but
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question
so what is the primary objective of
ethical hacker option A is to steal
sensitive information option b is to
comprise computer systems option C is to
identify vulnerabilities in option D to
spread virus now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below now let's start with the first
course on the list which is post
graduate program in cyber security so
this comprehensive course equips you
with the skills to safeguard your system
and data effectively from risk
assessment to compliance you'll gain
solid foundation in cyber security this
course is offered by simplylearn this
program offers a range of courses
spanning from fundamental to Advanced
levels and include prestigious industry
certifications key highlights of this
program includes simply learns
postgraduate certification upon
completion exclusive masterclass hosted
by MIT modules curated in collaboration
with MIT SCC and EC Council real world
cyber security case studies from various
Industries access to ceh kit for
Hands-On practice engage in 25 plus
practical projects to enhance your
skills then there is cumulate your
learning with a Capstone project across
three domains then you can also become a
part of MIT csail professional program
community
so these were the key highlights of this
program other than this you will be
delved into a diverse area of skills
including Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
ideas firewalls Security Management
cryptography and more so if you are
really interested to become a cyber
security expert then this course is for
you enrolling this program is really
easy apply online start by completing
the user-friendly online application
form share your details and intent to
join the cyber security certification
program second is selection our
admission panel will review the
applications and shortlist candidates
based on their qualifications and
aspirations then third is confirmation
if you're among the chosen candidates
you'll receive an offer of admission
secure a sport by paying the program fee
so this is how you can enroll in this
program so this was about postgraduate
program in cyber security by simply
learn now let's move on to the next
program which is cyber security expert
Masters program by Sinclair simply learn
cyber security expert Masters program is
designed to help cyber Security
Professionals to develop skills at
different levels that is foundational
intermediate and advanced these skills
are backed by top certifications like
ceh cism cissp and ccssp Etc the program
kicks off with basic technology training
and then moves to more advanced topics
like reverse engineering and network
penetrating testing Etc by completing
this course you will be able to first of
all stay updated keep yourself informed
about the latest cyber security Trends
learn how to implement effective
security measures using suitable
hardware and software for your
organization second would be defend
against phishing learn ethical security
practices to protect against phishing
attacks and other risks the third is
Embrace cloud computing understand the
importance of cloud computing for your
business and how to use it for Success
then there is ensure compliance get
familiar with legal requirements privacy
policies and auditing process for your
Cloud environment then after that there
is optimize it infrastructure streamline
your it setup and invest in right
software solutions for a well organized
infrastructure partner with experts who
have your best interest in Mind by the
time you complete this master's program
you will become skilled in handling
Advanced hacking Concepts which will
help you manage information security
effectively upon completion you will be
able to safeguard the moment of data
perform actions of recovering from
disasters manage security for client
databases and handle security aspects
related to cloud service providers and
many more things like that upon
completion of this Masters program you
will receive the certificates from
Simply learns in cyber security courses
in the learning path this certificate
will testify to your skills as an expert
in cyber security upon program
completion you will also receive an
industry recognize Master's certificate
from Simply learn so this was about
cyber security expert master's program
now move on to the next program which is
Advanced executive program in cyber
security this Advanced executive program
in cyber security will help you develop
expertise in defensive cyber security
application security malware analysis
ethical hacking Etc in partnership with
triple ID Bangalore and npci this
program is tailored to empower you with
the skills in defensive cyber security
ethical hacking malware analysis and
more by completing this program you earn
a prestigious certificate from triple it
Bangalore showcasing your accomplishment
engage in enlightening master classes
led by prop triple I to Bangalore
faculty gaining insights from their
wealth of knowledge moreover receive a
virtual internship certificate from npci
and reaching your practical experience
the course is designed for Hands-On
learning featuring over 30 demos and
multiple projects conducted in
integrated Labs with lifetime access to
self-paced videos you can learn at your
convenience a valuable it bangle
transcript validates your skills in
ethical hacking penetration testing
cryptography ransomware analysis malware
analysis Enterprise security network
Concepts and threat hunting this program
is your gateway for a promising future
in the dynamic of cyber security the
admission process for this Advanced
executive program in cyber security
consists of three easy steps interested
candidates will need to apply by
submitting the application from online
candidates will be shortlisted by an
admission panel for this PG in cyber
security based on the application
submitted then selected candidates will
be awarded an offer of admission that
they can accept by paying the program
fee Bond completion you will get the
final program completion certificate
from Simply learn individual course
completion certificate for all the
courses in the learning path from Simply
learn then there is executive program
certification from MIT certified ethical
hacker certificate from EC Council MIT
then there is professional program
Community membership also you will get
so these are all the things you'll get
in this Advanced executive program in
cyber security alright now let's move on
to the next best course which is
professional certificate program in
cyber security this professions educate
program in cyber security offered by IIT
kanpur in collaboration with simply
learn equips participants with expertise
to access the threat landscape and
device strategies for bolstering system
security and stability this program
facilitates the Mastery of vital cyber
security proficiencies through immersive
Hands-On training embedded in real world
scenarios completion of this program
Awards a certification from IIT kanpur
and simply learn candidates will gain
exclusive access to enlightening master
classes hosted by esteem IIT kanpur
faculty the curriculum criminates in a
practical Capstone project that engages
participants in Industry relevant use
cases fostering hands-on experience
simply learn learning management system
that is LMS provides seamless access to
integrated Labs enhancing practical
understanding the program
comprehensively covers essential skills
including ethical hacking cryptography
Concepts ideas firewalls and honeypots
network security vulnerability
assessment when it iteration testing and
web app threads the admission process
for this professional certificate
program in cyber security consists of
three easy steps that is interested
candidates will need to apply by
submitting the application from online
then candidates will be shortlisted by
admission panel then selected candidates
will be awarded an offer of admission
that they can accept by paying the
program fee now coming to the last
course which is Caltech cyber security
boot camp the Caltech cyber security
bootcamp offers a comprehensive learning
experience to master defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and more this
course equips you with practical
expertise using in demand cyber security
tools through Hands-On labs and guided
practices with a focus on Real World
skills the program covers network
security vulnerability assessment risk
management fed analysis business
continuity data privacy and security and
other things like digital forensics and
incident management by enrolling you can
earn a prestigious Caltech ctme bootcamp
certificate and add up to 26 CEUs along
with Caltech ckme Circle membership this
program's online convocation led by
program director adds to the experience
Additionally you will Master the
utilization of various Cutting Edge
tools equipping you for a successful
journey in the field of cyber security
so this was Caltech cyber security boot
camp so we have discussed five best
courses for ethical hacking the link of
these courses you'll get in the
description you can choose as per your
choice so alright guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it will help you all thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here